in my opinion they should have not done  this now what am i referring to the  scene where damon goes after the crab  field i was expecting a confrontation of  some kind or a scene of him killing the  crab feeder where instead this happened  off-screen instead we just see damon  dragging the corpse of the crabtree  against the ground now i can understand  why they might have chosen to do this  perhaps it would have ruined the pacing  of the episode or perhaps it was a  creative decision to show that the crab  theatre cannot fight and is not capable  of doing so so by showing this happened  off screen it then shows how worthless  to crab field actually was but what do  you guys think do you think this was a  good decision or do you wish we would  have saw this take place on screen let  me know in the comment section below if  you haven't already please do consider  subscribing thanks for watching guys